es ist eine absolute weltpremiere wenn
wir ein paar schritte zurückgehen müssen
um zwei personen zusammen komplett auf
ein bild zu bekommen ist das bei erde
und mond ein wenig schwieriger und
bisher hatte es noch niemand geschafft
hatte wohl gemerkt doch jetzt ist es der
nasa erstmals gelungen erde und mond aus
der entfernung zusammen auf ein bild zu
bekommen wie es aussieht wie die nasa
das hinbekommen hat jetzt bei pixum
science fiction herzlich willkommen
die erde und mond sind 390.000 kilometer
voneinander entfernt damit ist schon
einigermaßen klar dass sich ein fotograf
auch ungefähr in diesem entfernungs
bereich befinden muss wenn nicht weiter
weg um überhaupt ein foto machen zu
können in unserem fall ist es eine
fotografin und sie heißt wo sie riss rex
eigentlich ist die sonder auf dem weg zu
den asteroiden benno ein asteroid der
sich der erde gefährlich nähern könnte
in 150 jahren könnte das der fall sein
so etwa zwischen 2169 bis 2199 mit einem
eher geringen risiko 2135 kommt er nach
den bisherigen berechnungen der erde
näher als der mond und könnte dann durch
die gravitation von erde und mond auf
diesen kollisionskurs gebracht werden
trotz des geringen risikos ist er einer
der gefährlichsten bekannten asteroiden
bekannt ist hier entscheidend denn
nachuntersuchungen krachen jedes jahr
zwei größere hast du ihnen auf der erde
meistens in entlegenen gebieten oder in
einem einschlag winkel wie in china bis
2013 der nur sachschaden verursacht über
venlo will die nasa jetzt mehr wissen
und zwar damit auch über die entstehung
des sonnensystems und deshalb hat sie
die sonde zu ihm geschickt er ist ein
ideales untersuchungsobjekt 1999
entdeckt ist er mit 192 metern
durchmessern auf kurs zur erde und somit
relativ nah und sie ihre schränkt soll
2020 bodenproben von dem 62 millionen
tonnen schweren brocken nehmen und 2023
zurück zur erde bringen doch jetzt ist
wo sie ihre tracks auf seiner 600 50
millionen kilometer langen reise zur
benno in eine ideale position gekommen
um erde und mond auf einem bild
festzuhalten 5 millionen und 400 20.000
kilometer vom mond entfernt und 5
millionen 120.000 kilometer von der erde
klick das foto wurde schon im oktober
2017 geschossen aber erst jetzt so
berechnet dass es auch vernünftig
aussieht die beiden himmelskörper sind
nämlich unterschiedlich hell und so
musste das bild mehrmals gemacht werden
und dann zusammen gerechnet werden wie
bei einer hdr aufnahme also einer high
dynamic range aufnahme und voila hier
ist es der absolute wahnsinn vielleicht
lasse ich mir mal ein poster oder vom
machen die nase
fotos kann man ja ganz einfach und
erlaubt herunterladen und belichten
lassen
mal sehen ich habe ja noch als von der
ss was meint ihr solche die man hinter
mir hier aufhängen ein kleiner
depotwechsel schreibe es in die
kommentare
und wenn er auf dem laufenden zur benno
mission bleiben wollt dieses jahr
erreicht die sonde bereits den
asteroiden bringt mehr hier ein abo aufs
auge und vergessen ich den genau auf die
glocke und dann werdet ihr auch immer
über neue videos informiert hier geht es
weiter mit und dafür draufklicken hast
du ihn und bedrohen die erde jederzeit
da gibt es mehr infos zu dem ständigen
einschläge von asteroiden auf der erde
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran